it's friday's the first full day of
california one i went through absolute
hell to get here i was supposed to fly
out at quarter six in the morning on
thursday out of boston now that's a
little bit of a drive for me and as a
result i did stay overnight in a hotel
so that i wouldn't be driving in an
ungodly hour in the morning well when i
got to the airport it turned out that
the flight crew was too tired to
continue and there was no backup flight
crew so they bumped me to a later flight
that meant i couldn't even check my bags
for another four hours after i had
already been there now instead one
connection i suddenly had three so i get
to baltimore and now suddenly while
waiting on a plane that would take me to
chicago for my last connection there's
weather in chicago that is causing a
delay a delay that might cost me
catching my connection so i kind of get
lucky in that they put me on a direct
flight from baltimore to la but then
once i got to la found out my luggage
and my bags didn't make the change with
me so i had to wait another hour at the
airport for those to show up i missed
the entire pre-launch party of the
convention but you know what i'm here
now and
i am ready
for this